avec ses 20 mètres de hauteur le
chevalement du musée de la mine de
blanzy domine fièrement le paysage et le
puy saint claude
comme un symbole ils témoignent de 200
ans d'exploitation du charbon mais plus
qu'un vestige il continue de fonctionner
grâce à une poignée de bénévoles
passionnés
alors le plan des sentiments
[Musique]
le site par lui-même elle seule qui lie
à sur la région le chevalement que nous
aurons une autre tête c'est cette chose
là c'est le seul qui reste il y en a
plus c'est la seule chose qui montre
enfin de compte qu'on est dans un pays
qui a vécu grâce au charbon
à l'autre bout du treuil pour faire
descendre les hommes et remonter le
charbon cette machine de 1885 fabriqués
à chalon sur saône
elle aurait pu partir à la casse sont la
prise de conscience de quelques uns en
ces pionniers pressent fait que le
patrimoine minier risquer de disparaître
aujourd'hui la belle ron une rareté dans
le monde parce que celle ci et là en
état de fonctionnement en allemagne à la
mène seulement elle ne fonctionne pas
rien n'a pas 36 ans moi reconnaissance
juin inclus dans ce musée
l'immersion dans l'univers des mineurs
se poursuit avec la découverte d'une
galerie à blanzy le charbon est si près
de la surface qu'il suffit de faire
quelques pas pour aller au fond et
découvrir l'évolution des techniques
d'extraction de la pioche à ce plat tu
auras beau fleuron technologique des
années 80 en toile lui nous fait une
démonstration avec cette pelleteuse tout
droit sorti de l'entre-deux-guerres
investissant j'aï simenel étaient payés
au synthé m un centimètre c'est à dire
en une journée vous faisait combien sont
ils ont donné un médecin contre trois
personnes une industrie qui avait donc
un grand besoin de main d'oeuvre à son
apogée en 1900 la compagnie des mines
faisait livre 12000 personnes dont dix
mille mineurs
blanzy montceau les mines sanvignes sur
une bande de 15 km plus de 200 puits
forages et caro exister et si
aujourd'hui presque tout a disparu
la marque de la mine se fait toujours
sentir sur l'urbanisme
voici le quartier du bois-du-verne à
montceau une cité minière construite en
1852 avec son plan typique de rue
perpendiculaire et ses petites maisons
mitoyennes par 4 ou par deux chacune
disposant d'un jardin c'était pour
éviter l'habitat collectif l'habitat
collectif était jugé trop dangereux pour
des guérisons de santé bien sûr je pense
qu'en ce moment on s'en rend compte
et puis pour des raisons de prosélytisme
politique à des mineurs n'avaient rien à
faire en rentrant pouvait c'est chauffé
les esprits s'étaient très mauvais pour
la compagnie des mines
donc le jardin c'était une façon pour
ces hommes qui venaient de la terre pour
la plupart c'est une façon de retrouver
ce contact avec la terre et de les
occuper et d'avoir la paix sociale
le patrimoine industriel n'a pas
tellement en corse la faveur des
touristes c'est un petit peu qui est
dommage
même les non c'est bien si volant
demandé est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose à
voir ils vont vous répondre non alors
qu'en fait il ya beaucoup de choses à
qui sait regarder car ici aucune cité
minière n'a été classé aux monuments
historiques
mais les traces de ce passé enfoui celui
du charbon et de ces gueules noires
affleure sous les crépis des maisons
[Musique]